♪ (intro music) ♪
Mobile screens are small,
so apps often use iconography
to convey meaning.
They're also full of images
and other visual content
that might not be obvious
and that is inaccessible to people
with impaired vision.
To keep users informed, used Tooltips.
Just wrap your content
with a Tooltip widget
and provide a message.
Now, your icons and images
show Tooltips when appropriate.
For example, when the user
taps through the UI,
or when they [long] press on it,
Tooltip exports the message
into semantics,
so screen readers
will be able to vocalize them.
You can customize your Tooltips
with vertical offset, height, and more.
Some Material widgets, like IconButton,
already include Tooltips,
so you can just provide the message text.
For more info on those
and all the other widgets,
head to flutter.io
♪ (music) ♪